bonjour alexis ravi de vous retrouver
dans cette matinale d'ayrté france en
vrai en point de presse ce matin entre
13000 et et 15000 on va pas chipoter
personnes à villepinte pour eric zemmour
5000 à la défense pour jean luc
mélenchon les candidats ont essayé une
démonstration de force pour lancer leur
campagne respective qu'en avez-vous
pensé oui clairement on a vu les deux
formations là se mettre en ordre de
bataille alors pour réviser moore
s'était nouveau un puisqu'il dévoilait
le nom de son parti reconquête on a eu
la remonte à dallas et la reconquête
avec un reconquis star espagnole en
ligne de mire aussi plus de dix mille
personnes à villepinte à la même date le
même lieu aussi où avaient été laissées
en 1976 le rpr puisque il se il se dit
héritier aussi de cette droite là
souverainiste donc un succès du côté
d'eric zemmour malgré les violences on a
vu des militants des sceaux est racisme
qui avaient un t-shirt non au racisme
qui ont été attaqués le service d'ordre
est intervenue et puis eric zemmour
aussi qui a été pris à partie lors de
son arrivée sur scène de son entourage
certains disent qu'il aurait eu le
poignet abîmé neuf jours indique t t
qui sont recommandées aux candidats
s'est pas arrêté pour autant oui et puis
du côté de jean luc mélenchon alors là
c'était 5000 personnes à la défense
environ avec de l'ariège l'idée
d'installer ce gouvernement enfin ce
parlement populaire l'union populaire
c'est le nouveau nom de la france
insoumise l'idée c'est d'aller plus
large de rassembler à gauche d'être la
gauche de la gauche enfin la gauche
républicaine face à une gauche qui pour
le moment a du mal à décoller que ce
soit yannick jadot ou la maire de paris
anne hidalgo et là on avait deux visions
de la france vraiment à villepinte et à
la défense d'un côté et à jean luc
mélenchon qui dit la france n'existe pas
sans la république et puis de l'autre à
eric zemmour qui est dans une autre
tradition ou la république ok mais
surtout la france donc c'est vraiment
important de voir comment ces deux
formations vont peut-être être les plus
importantes dans cette campagne qui
arrive parce que il ya là un débat
d'idées fondamental dans la façon dont
on envisage le pays alors il ya aussi
les républicains y sont lancés dans la
campagne valérie pécresse la candidate
désignée en congrès mais déjà des
tensions internes oui alors valérie
pécresse est sorti du vote du congrès
avec 63% des votes il me semble ce qui
fait quand même quasiment 40% des votes
pour l'élection tic qui était quasiment
seul puisque tous les autres candidats
avaient appelé à voter valérie pécresse
s'est beaucoup est d'ores et déjà eric
ciotti lançons mouvement explique qu' il
ne faudrait pas que valérie pécresse
oublie ce mouvement fort important que
eric ciotti représente donc on voit
l'accolade entre eric ciotti et et
valérie pécresse qui ressemble déjà un
peu
voilà en disant attention c'est
peut-être un de blagues qui va falloir
mettre en place au moins une gestion à
2,2 de ce parti des républicains sachant
que lors du meeting d'eric zemmour vous
aviez par exemple guillaume pelletier
des républicains qui appelait à une
union des droites avec eric ciotti qui
pourrait rejoindre eric zemmour encore
une affaire d'eric et puis également à
la tribune vous aviez des appels puisque
marquez hauts responsables les
républicains pour rejoindre ce nouveau
pôle de droite qui est reconquête donc
valérie pécresse va avoir du mal je
pense à tenir des troupes qui ont voté
massivement pour lectio ti et qui vont
sans doute regarder plus du côté d'eric
zemmour que de son côté à elle et puis
on va terminer par ce lundi que les
jours de conseil de défense
exceptionnellement un lundi de quoi
brouiller donc cette entrée en campagne
retentissante par des nouvelles annonces
surprises de mâcon oui il ya le timing
évidemment je pense qu'il n'est pas
anodin ça permet aussi de brouiller le
bruit médiatique de ces deux meetings
politiques importants et tout de suite
d'embrayer sur autre chose les médias
vous devons parler que de ces nouvelles
réponses alors comment on va être mangé
cette fois ci est ce qu'on va être
confiné est ce que ce sera pas plus de 6
à noël est ce qu'on va pouvoir sortir
papis et mamies du balcon est ce que les
enfants vont aller à l'école ou pas on
ne sait pas alors là oui c'est une
avalanche de kara le papa dans les
hôpitaux heureusement mais on voit bien
que emmanuel macron envie de reprendre
ce conseil sanitaires à chaque semaine
il l'a dit lui même et puis il ya la
conférence de presse de jeudi qui est
déjà annoncée où il va parler de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne donc on voit bien que du côté
du candidat président même s'il n'est
pas encore officiellement président
clairement il veut débranché au plus
vite à l'entrée en campagne fracassante
d'eric zemmour et de jean-luc mélenchon
et bien sûr des républicains répondre
j'imagine merci beaucoup alexis c'était
l'édito politique de la matinale